hello doctor ooh well yeah nice white
shirt all right
[Music]
what's happening y'all john baptiste
here and these are my essentials
[Music]
man my life has been
very blessed i have seen people from all
walks of life
and realize that
just like you know when you watch
forrest gump he just will run across all
these historic moments
i wanted to document it these cameras
are special because
you can take a photo and document the
moment and give it to the person and i
just have
over the last few years
so many incredible moments captured with
this camera and a few others i just felt
like i need to be capturing this stuff i
feel like forrest gump i feel like
dumping this mug when i was a kid
growing up we have all these photos and
you know after hurricane katrina we lost
a lot of pictures this life is so
fleeting right
and you get to these moments where you
can see things that were important to
you
in a picture
and it just brings you to a perspective
of how special it is to be here see it's
coming together see it
man it's coming together
i'm a gamer fully through and through
you ever play games ever since i was a
kid i played games and when this came
out the super nintendo mini
i was so happy
you have games that are built into the
system and you can take it with you
anywhere and just with a hdmi cable you
can plug it into the tv i got like 15 20
games from my childhood
right here now nba 2k
you can't hold me on this i'm fired on
this game i'm an expert i got a degree
in this game i'm probably as good at
this as i am at piano i play with the
bulls you know
the legacy teams i just like to shut
shut down sometimes and zone in
life is is is is very very
full
and sometimes i like to
shut off my blank brain shut it off not
not completely but just to to get to a
point where you
are connected to a fantasy realm and
you're controlling this avatar and
you're in this other world for a minute
and you can just explore things and and
be a superhero be
anthony davis uh lebron and i must say
on the record the greatest game ever
made they did a remake on the ps4 final
fantasy vii
i could cry thinking about that game
video games super essential
insoles very very essential
you see i'm a dancer i'm a performer and
when i go out
and i dance for hours
my feet because they're particularly
flat need extra support
these are comfort fit insoles they were
custom molded to my foot and i've been
wearing insoles since i was a teenager i
would be very embarrassed when i was a
teenager and i had to wet his insoles
but i've come to love these these are
the kind of things that i put in my my
jordans which i think you know these
shoes are probably my most
frequented shoes i feel like they're
some of the most comfortable versatile
shoes ever made and when you put these
together for me john baptiste
we feeling good down there
yeah it's gq so we got to talk about
clothing
[Music]
this
first piece
is a
wonderful
pair of
sweat pants this is by one of my
favorite brands
ron they really know how to
make stuff that just feels
so comfortable that you never want to
take it off and it looks great so when
you wear it for days on end it doesn't
look crusty it doesn't look like oh boy
better take that thing off if i go on a
road sometimes if i'm going overseas and
i can go for weeks at a time with just a
carry-on bag
and in that bag it'll be
probably like five six pairs of these
and this is the other thing
any form of letterman this is like a
coach
letterman type jacket
and the combination of this
with
any old generic hoodie
almost year-round
i'm in this when you put these together
this situation
is john bates
this is me
i and and with the jays and the insoles
from earlier and the head scarf
sometimes i throw a grill in there
that's it that's literally it
and then uh
these are the grills that go with the
uniform these are some of the grills
that i have
they they really are actual gold and
actual diamonds in it i got recommended
to this place by asap rocky i like to do
offset like the fangs
like this right here because the energy
of that is it's it's like is he ratchet
is he
that guy
you don't know if you have it in from
afar it's like what's happening with
that so yeah i like that i like that
kind of energy
[Music]
oh
being life the bean life
[Music]
this is a can of red kidney beans which
i consider to be the best bean in the
world we grew up in new orleans eating
beans every monday as a tradition people
from the knoll you know that beans on
mondays are a tradition that we can
never forsake let me just give you a
cooking lesson real quick
the holy trinity of cooking cajun
cooking is you gotta have your onion
your celery stalk
and your green peppers you mix it all
together you get a little olive oil you
can add all kinds of other things you
can add your broths to it some seasons
you know i got all kind of seasonings
that a a special recipe i can't tell you
but you can get some cajun seasoning
somewhere the generic will do you good
for not you you put all of that in the
pot with your beans you mix it all
together you cook it let it let it be on
the on the boil for about a good eight
hours once you have your beans prepared
you can eat your beans all throughout
the winter season that's coming up you
can eat your beans on mondays to follow
the tradition of new orleans you can eat
your beans anytime that you want a snack
you can have them on the side stuff you
can make a bean stew you can have beans
and rice which is what i love to make i
take this on the road with me wherever i
go and love to make these
in
many forms
all right so
this is uh
show day
tour
travel day
essentials
[Music]
dressing room essentials
john baptiste care package right here
for anybody who wants to get me
something for christmas
this is what i consider to be what i
need in order to feel like i'm ready to
hit the stage
even more so than
wardrobe even sometimes more so than
knowing what instrument i'm gonna be
playing these things are are
throat coat
that i preach a lot in the show i sing a
lot in the show there's so much that's
happening
when um
you use your voice like that that you
can't control when the spirit moves you
it just is going you ain't you can't do
nothing about it you gotta preemptively
protect your voice
and in that tradition the brothers
pastels
a great way to lubricate the the voice
the throat you just put it under your
tongue tastes good it's really nice it's
i would literally
eat this like candy if you don't want to
if you're not a singer you're not
somebody who use your voice a lot just
get these just cause
it tastes good
manuka honey it's not even about a brand
this is from whole foods just manuka
honey the healing properties of honey
when you put that honey on your throat
mavis staples one of the great
artists civil rights activists she said
the the manuka honey that's that's what
she uses and she's still up there
singing and killing it
this is lip balm
this is
like what it sounds like
you put it on your lips i have some
beautiful black man lips so for me when
i have my lips chapped i just don't feel
right i need bomb so
there's that
and then then you know this on the days
before the show i like to wrap my hair
if i'm rehearsing and i'm with getting a
routine together the choreography i like
to not sweat my eyes out and this is
just a thing i usually do on sundays in
fact when we were in the deep part of
the lockdown everybody was locked down
at home i would do the dance with john's
on sundays on my instagram and i would
dance with people from all over the
world for hours at a time
and i would just have my head wrapped
because
the sweat
coming down into your eyes you'd be on
on your live and you look like you've
been um
doing the l
i don't smoke by the way i don't endorse
that for the kids
watch it and then basically a foam
roller you can get any kind of generic
foam roller i'm just like
trying to stay loose and stay in flow
state
all the time
so you got to roll it out
oh
so i'm one of those dudes i like to read
a few things at the same time a very
associative thinker i like things that
falling into the other pot and then you
see what you're cooking later on when
you make the connections yourself the
subconscious is always working and i'm
writing a symphony that's going gonna
premiere next year at carnegie hall it's
very big deal for me because it's it's
it's over 200 musicians it's not just
the orchestra it's the first black
orchestra feature that carnegie hall in
the history is marching band and chorus
and my band and i'm conducting and i'm
playing and symphony is called american
symphony so right now this is what i'm
dealing with so this book by howard zinn
is something i'm reading right now as
i'm editing and finishing the piece it's
a favorite of mine
a people's history of the united states
1492 to the present and just the
perspective whether you agree with his
perspective or not just his way of
telling the story and conceptualizing it
and the people that he remembers in the
story that aren't often remembered
is very inspiring when trying to
conceptualize a piece like the one that
i'm composing prince
this is about his process
i got a chance to meet prince
and play with him when i was 19. ever
since then i always have been enamored
with his process you know him as an
artist him as a performer it's all great
obviously but the process is really
interesting when you're in your own
process i like to take things that i
like from other people's process and you
know leave the things i don't like but
in leaving you've defined yourself and
then this is another book about process
process of film scoring when you're
talking about orchestra you're talking
about film score and i will say that
this by earl hagan is one of the
definitive books for anybody whether you
want to be a composer for films you want
to work in orchestras you want to work
developing themes
then this is
they're like five composers
who when i'm working on something or
when i'm just
looking for inspiration i'm playing the
music or i'm listening to the music
beethoven is one of them this is a book
of some of his sonatas you know if you
come to a show of mine if you see me
sometime around the piano i'm liable to
play
one of these five composers including
beethoven just messing around with it
taking it apart putting it back together
finding ways to just like figure it out
and get to know these people better
because they're not around but i believe
we are with them when we play their
music
so speaking of music this is my next
essential and you may have seen me play
it before
goes by many names melodica
melody horn
harmona board that's what i like to call
it harmonica and the keyboard put
together it's one of my favorite things
because it can go anywhere that i go
i can't take my piano with me everywhere
but i can take this with me and it's one
of those things that i've done for many
years
even when i was
first coming into new york
as a teenager and moving around the
subway i would play it and people would
start seeing me on the subway and they
would recognize me for for being the kid
that's blowing that thing that they want
me to stop playing
and then things changed and they were
like can you play it and then
now i'm playing it on tv i just like how
averse to pomposity it is it's a kid's
toy
and it's not meant to be played like a
serious instrument but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think the phone is it because
man
steve jobs
wow i don't i don't really use a laptop
anymore i don't really mess with email
if i didn't have this phone i probably
would be unreachable
you can go
and listen to or research or
basically consume anything at any time
it's crazy it's addictive as well so i
would advise also having time where you
don't have it but it's essential when
you need it
that was it everybody it's john baptiste
thank you all for letting me share my
essentials with you i see you down the
road maybe at carnegie hall if you
practice practice
practice
[Music]